bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 6 juillet il y à 60 millions 82
mille habitants en france le chiffre
officiel du recensement effectué cette
année deux millions de plus qu'il y a
neuf ans et quelques villes en forte
croissance dont nantes toulouse
montpellier et lyon
un officier mauritanien a interpellé et
emprisonné en france pour crimes de
torture commis en 1990 dans son pays la
mauritanie prend des mesures de
rétorsion contre cette action judiciaire
française les opposants slobodan
milosevic manifeste en serbie il lance
une campagne baptisée le temps est venu
de nous séparer danse mon festival de
montpellier avec l'union du cinéma et de
la chorégraphie grâce à philippe
decouflé pour bien se connaître il faut
se compter du moins était seul 1 des
bûches du recensement effectué au début
de cette année les premiers résultats
ont été publiés aujourd'hui nous sommes
donc un peu plus de 60 millions de
personnes habitant sur l'ensemble du
territoire français
ce chiffre s'accompagne de détails qui
révèlent des inégalités dans la
croissance de la population selon les
régions et selon les villes
globalement la croissance démographique
française est inférieure dans les années
90 par rapport à celle constatée dans
les années 80 explication hélène vers
didier deshamps et christophe vignal
pour le dernier recensement du siècle la
barre des 60 millions d'habitants est
franchie désormais nous sommes très
exactement 60 millions 82000 à résider
sur le territoire français soit une
progression de 0 38 % par an depuis le
dernier recensement en 1990 plus de 50
millions de français vivent aujourd'hui
en métropole contre un million six cent
soixante cinq mille cinq cent dans les
dom les départements d'outre-mer
la ville sans surprise continue toujours
d'attirer les français 80% la
choisissent au détriment des campagnes
mais pas n'importe quelle ville ce sont
les grandes agglomérations régionales
qui ont désormais la cote
paris sacro-sainte capitale voit fuir
ses habitants au profit de non plus lyon
toulouse aix et montpellier des sites et
dynamique à visage humain sont les
villes de 200 me à 310 habitants qui
sont plébiscités c'est à dire les villes
dans lesquelles il fait bon vivre les
villes qui sont encore à l'échelle
humaine
deux cent mille trois cent mille
habitants c'est suffisant pour avoir une
vie culturelle pour avoir une vie
sportive etc et donc ça c'est aussi ce
qui est plébiscité par les français
c'est ce que montre le recensement
douceur de vivre meilleure qualité de
vie le bord de mer est le grand gagnant
démographique de cette fin de siècle le
littoral atlantique et le grand sud
ouest ont su attirer séduire les
français
tout comme l'alsace et la région rhône
elle l'auvergne le limousin la champagne
ardenne font en revanche triste mine et
conjugue baisse de la natalité aidé par
la population française a donc progressé
mais plus lentement que prévu six mois
seront encore nécessaires à l'insee pour
conclure cette opération complexe et
coûteuse ce recensement aura coûté 1,2
milliard de francs alors avec ses 60
millions 82 mille habitants je le répète
recensé la france est après l'allemagne
le pays le plus peuplé de l'union
européenne ce sont les régions sud qui
semblent être les plus prisés avec en
premier lieu l'agglomération toulousaine
qui compte désormais sept cent quarante
et un mille habitants l'attraction pour
toulouse et ses communes environnantes
donc bien réel reportage christophe la
rocha et patrice chavaudra désormais
c'est la 5ème agglomérations de france
juste devant bordeaux son éternel rival
plus trente deux mille habitants pour
toulouse intra muros plus 90 mille
habitants pour l'ensemble de
l'agglomération
les chiffres annoncés ce matin par
l'insee sont impressionnants ils le sont
plus encore si l'on considère la zone d'
influence de la métropole soit la
progression de toutes les communes dont
40 % des résidents travaillent à
toulouse c'est une très très forte
progression sur les années 90 ses 120
mille habitants en plus dans son contour
de l'airé urbaine de toulouse en atteint
917 mille habitants pour la zone d'
influence de toulouse
bénéfices immédiats pour la ville plus
de moyens car l'état accorde chaque
année une dotation de 1650 francs par
habitant aux communes soit pour toulouse
une rallonge de près de 53 millions de
francs davantage d'habitants ça veut
dire davantage d'écoles davantage
d'enseignants davantage de salles de
classes davantage d'équipements sportifs
et culturels et appartements où la
population d'une ville augmente l'état
accorde à cette ville de bunia
supplémentaires pour répondre aux
besoins des habitants
de quoi financer les nouveaux quartiers
qui ont fleuri dans la ville rose depuis
15 et surtout il maintenir les services
publics indispensables pour l'instant
l'insee est incapable de dire pourquoi
toulouse a connu une telle croissance
bien sûr il y à la réussite économique
de la ville dans les hautes technologies
mais aux terrasses des cafés ça n'est
pas le premier à tous que l'on met en
oeuvre on ressent voile le stress que
qu'à paris ou dans nos deux villes de
france
pas de les gens semblent détendus moi je
travaillerai milieux d'affaires et c'est
l'impression que ça soit beaucoup plus
détendu que le pin à hesdin il y à
l'océan ya la mer yann skis l'hiver
l'ambiance la nuit bref tout ce que l'on
appelle en authentique langage
statisticiens un véritable effet sud et
la répartition de la population
française connaît aussi un changement
constant en faveur des villes moyennes
éloignées notamment du centre de la
capitale parisienne c'est l'effet des
villes nouvelles qui se poursuit mais
celles ci restent encore trop souvent
des villes dortoirs
voici une enquête que nous avons menée
en seine et marne à lognes avec valérie
gages à l'udc bachofen quelques maison
nichée au pied d'une église un monument
aux morts et une fontaine village il y
allons
il y a vingt ans l'homme n'était encore
que cela un village briard entouré de
champs la rue de la mairie n'avait guère
changé depuis l'époque de ces photos
prises au début du siècle
ginette dos santos est l'un des rares
témoins de ce passé rural
elle se souvient encore de l'école qui
jouxtait la mairie là c'était la cour
les arbres sont là bas j'ai toujours
connu surtout celui-là cela réserve est
un peu plus jeune est dans le coin là
vous aviez un préau avec les cabinets ce
qu'on appelait les cabinets en rang
d'oignons mellon aujourd'hui n'a plus
rien d'un village en vingt ans sa
population a été multipliée par 57 2 248
habitants 77
on est arrivé à près de 15000 en 95
autour du vieux centre la ville s'est
répandue comme une traînée de poudre
d'abord vers l'ouest puis
progressivement vers l'est
je trouve que ça fait très très vite
trop vite peut-être une ville
traditionnelle auraient grossi comme ça
on s'entend nous on l'a fait en 25 ans
ici malgré les apparences pas
d'urbanisation sauvage tout a été
planifié carlo n'y fait partie de la
ville nouvelle de marne-la-vallée
organisé ou pas l'urbanisation a gagné
toutes les communes situées dans la
périphérie des grandes villes
en ile de france cette carte montre bien
comment les parisiens ont délaissé le
centre pour aller se loger de plus en
plus loin jean-pierre luquand est de
ceux là
allon il a construit sa maison pour
avoir la verdure s'enlise allemand on se
sent proche de paris et alors il faut
savoir que le nerf de la guerre du pour
un lieu comme celui ci c'est le rer
on sait qu'il ya des moments faut pas
prendre sa voiture mais on sait qu'avec
le métro on est dans paris donc on a ce
ce cordon ombilical qui permet vraiment
de se sentir quand même très proche de
la capitale
mais cette proximité 33 minutes en rer
pose aussi problème
à lognes deux habitants sur trois
travaille à paris ou en proche banlieue
pour perdre ses allures de dortoir
la ville doit inverser le sens des
déplacements il ya beaucoup d'emplois
sur place j'espère qu'au fur et à mesure
les habitants qui le font le chemin
inverse pour venir travailler sur la
commune décideront d'habiter dans la
ville et comme cela nous trouverons un
réel équilibre entre habitat et emploi
l'urbanisation entraîne aussi un
otage des espaces naturels ce verger où
ce champ de maïs résisteront-ils
longtemps à l'avancé des bulldozer
certains experts estiment qu'il faudra
aider les communes périphériques à
résister à la pression foncière en les
dédommageant si au lieu de construire
elle préserve des espaces verts sinon en
ile de france comme ailleurs les gens
continueront à s'agglutiner dans les
banlieues les allemands trouver une
solution il construit maîtrise
occupation du sol l'intercommunalité
très développé et construisent ce qu'ils
appellent des villes en grappe comme des
grappes de raisin il y avait des b c'est
à dire que plutôt que d'avoir une ville
d'un million d'habitants
ils ont quatre villes de 250 pour le
développement des villes et signe de
modernité
ce n'est donc pas forcément un mal à
condition de ne pas franchir le seuil
qui sépare croissance et excroissance en
une
l'emploi ou l'environnement un débat
pervers est posée à bourg-fidèle dans le
département des ardennes une usine de
traitement de batteries responsable
d'une pollution au plomb doit être
fermée sur décision de justice
le député local parle d'une décision
idiote et imbécile et les salariés de
l'usiné montrent une sorte de vraies
fausses séquestration de leur direction
pour éviter la fermeture de l'entreprise
le tout vous est maintenant raconté par
louis carzou et alexis delcourt les
salariés mobilisés contre une décision
de justice prises pour les protéger et
qui font le piquet devant leur usine
pour en garantir le bon fonctionnement
telle est la situation pour le moins
paradoxale de l'entreprise métal blanc a
beau fidèles dans les ardennes cette
usine spécialisée dans le retraitement
de batterie est officiellement fermée
depuis hier sur décision de justice
motif une pollution constante surtout au
plomb depuis près de 30 ans malgré les
rappels à l'ordre la mise aux normes a
traîné alors la justice a fini par
frapper et prononcé la fermeture mais
encore trop vite au goût des salariés
auxquels la direction fait craindre la
fermeture pure et simple de lusine seule
source d'emplois pour le village des
ardennes ça paye de fonderie on croyait
que il ya aucune usine qui polluent
métal blanc se met aux normes depuis
déjà pas mal d'années ils vont souhaite
encore plus au nom de l'homme mais qu'on
leur laisse le temps au moins qu'on leur
laisse le temps où hier lundi la
situation semblait s'être tendu avec la
retenus contre leur gré du pdg et du
directeur de l'usiné à l'intérieur des
locaux mais c'est le directeur lui-même
qui a guidé notre passage dans
l'entreprise cet après-midi et le
parquet de charleville mézières émet de
sérieux doutes sur la réalité de la
séquestration du président de métal
blanc qui fait par ailleurs l'objet
d'une convocation au quai savez je
laisse toujours comédiens l'art de la
mise en scène c'est pas un rôle dévolu
aux industriels je ne crois pas
les éléments dispose bien entendu qu'une
séquestration je crois qu'il ya une
volonté de passer outre et comme je vous
le disais cette volonté de passer outre
et une infraction pénale
reste les habitants du village simples
riverains de l'usiné pour lesquels la
patience n'a décidément rien d'une vertu
qui comprend qu'ils veulent s'y défend
c'est normal puisqu'il travaille si on
faire de vagues
il faut pas qu'ils nous envoient ya nous
aussi parce qu'il faut que personne que
moi c'est la santé de mes filles je me
bats pas contre je me bats contre la
pollution
s'il veut pas la stopper site oui je
crois qu'il ya pas d'autre solution que
la fermeture de l usine et devant le
taux de plomb relevé dans le sens de ses
deux filles plus du double du maximum
toléré après un an du traitement nelly
elle a décidé de quitter bon final le
président de la république achever
aujourd'hui son déplacement de 48 heures
dans le bordelais par une sorte de
déjeuner champêtre à saint-émilion une
ville qui fête cette année le 800e
anniversaire de sa création
monsieur chirac est intervenu dans
plusieurs secteurs de la vie politique
et économique utilisant ses rencontres
avec des chefs d'entreprise pour
rappeler qu'il est favorable à une
baisse des prélèvements fiscaux
reportage véronique sainte odile et jean
cornu plongée au coeur du centre de
simulation nucléaire une haute
technologie qui fonctionne grâce aux
données obtenues avec les derniers décès
de mu ruraux à 195,8 hommage au
scientifique jacques chirac prend
exemple sur ce laboratoire d'aquitaine
pour vanter la décentralisation et
l'activité locale et surtout pour
critiquer des impôts qu'ils estiment
trop lourd et qui entraînerait selon lui
une fuite des cerveaux
une leçon destiné au premier ministre
nous connaissons actuellement une
croissance soutenue elle crée de
nouvelles et marge de manoeuvre pour nos
finances publiques
c'est une période très favorable pour
mettre en oeuvre les réformes qui
renforceront l'efficacité de la
puissance publique au bénéfice des
citoyens tout en allégeant les
prélèvements qui pèsent sur l'activité
et l'emploi
dernière étape d'un déplacement de 48
heures sur les terres d'alain juppé avec
une halte à saint-émilion déjeuner
populaire pour finir deux mille
personnes ont payé 50 francs pour
partager avec le président de la
république carottes râpées et
charcuterie un exercice que jacques
chirac affectionne à l'exercice de
campagne présidentielle ici loin des
parties le président de la république a
d'abord voulu resserrer des liens
directs avec tous les français
on a appris aujourd'hui le décès de
l'industriel et homme politique louis
ducatel il était âgé de 97 ans et il fut
candidat à l'élection présidentielle de
on voit ici des images de cette
candidature et puis philippe seguin a va
aller enseigner à l'université du québec
à montréal pour un an en études
stratégiques et diplomatiques donc à
cette université du québec à montréal
pour un an à compter de septembre
prochain
pour philippe seguin un juge
d'instruction de montpellier a mis en
examen pour crimes de torture un
capitaine des forces armées
mauritaniennes celui ci était écroué a
été écroué il effectue un stage de à
l'école d'application d'infanterie de
l'armée française installée à
montpellier
les faits reprochés auraient été commis
en 1986 1991 les autorités
mauritaniennes ont décidé en
représailles le départ des coopérants
militaires français commentaires eric
monier avec véronique église
c'est dans l'enceinte même de cette
école l'école du commissariat de l'armée
de terre à montpellier où il était en
stage que l'officier mauritanien a été
arrêté le capitaine et le wild a a été
mis en examen suite à un dépôt de
plainte de deux organisations de défense
de droits de l'homme
deux anciens officiers mauritanien
l'accusent de torture ce matin dans le
quotidien libération l'une des victimes
livre quelques détails sur les méthodes
présumé du capitane houlda on vous
attache les mains et les pieds on vous
met à plat ventre et il frappe avec des
fils électriques
on ne pouvait même pas s'asseoir encore
moins s'allonger pour se reposer on
mettait les pieds sur quelqu'un chacun
son tour
il s'agit pas d' exactions limitée et de
véritables tortures au sens où l'entend
dans le cadre des textes internationaux
de répression de la torture et du code
pénal français c'est en s'appuyant
justement sur la convention
internationale contre la torture
signée par la france qu'un juge français
a envoyé le capitane ould à dormir dans
cette prison une première en france
puisqu'il s'agit de faits s'ils sont
avérés remontant à 1990 commis par un
étranger sur un étranger dans un pays
étranger
une innovation juridique qui n'a pas
l'heur de plaire au président
mauritanien ould taille
cet ami de la france a décidé hier le
renvoi des coopérants militaires
français et le rétablissement des visas
d'entrée pour les ressortissants france
en mauritanie une loi à moustier toutes
infractions criminelles commises entre
89 et 92 au nom de la réconciliation
nationale
est ce que cette réconciliation mais
finalement pas l'objectif premier de la
justice internationale est ce que cette
justice internationale peut au nom de
principes mettre à néant tous les
efforts fournis par ce pays une affaire
qui complique les relations entre la
france et l'un de ses partenaires
privilégiés et qui illustre le conflit
entre exigence de justice et pragmatisme
politique en serbie les manifestations
d'opposition à slobodan milosevic succès
d'une campagne organisée par des
syndicats et des organisations non
gouvernementales vient d'être lancé avec
un slogan
le temps est venu de nous séparer mais
ses différentes marques d'opposition ne
semble guère émouvoir slobodan milosevic
commentaires patrice romedenne en ce
mardi 6 juillet monsieur et madame
milosevic son sort à la poignée de main
entre le président yougoslave et son
homologue serbe milan milutinovic
les deux hommes ont en commun d'être
sous le coup d'une inculpation du
tribunal pénal international pour crimes
contre l'humanité
il est ici question de célébrer le 58e
anniversaire du soulèvement des serbes
contre l'occupation allemande pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale à la cérémonie
le gratin de la police et celui de
l'armée ont été conviés un peu comme si
les dignitaires du régime voulait
médiatiser une sérénité à laquelle la
rue elles donnent un écho dissonant
quelques vingt mille personnes hier
leskovac de 150km au sud de belgrade
initialement la manifestation vise un
responsable politique local en route
le cortège s'en prend à milosevic dont
il réclame la démission qu'on appelle au
changement au fustige les voleurs la
police ne bronche pas dans un sens dit
cette jeune femme a c'est notre manière
de marquer le renouveau de notre pays et
de notre ville
on l'a mérité cela fait trop longtemps
que nous nous taisons ras le bol des
guerres s'emporte celui ci ont menacé de
tout ce qui se passe en serbie arrêté
hier l'organisateur de cette
manifestation a été condamné à un mois
de prison et à l'or semble dire les
étudiants de niche où l'assemblée
municipale de novi sad qui réclament
aujourd'hui à leur tour la démission
milosevic et la libéralisation des
médias dans ce brouhaha
un homme fait irruption vue grâce kovic
jadis opposant puis rallié à milosevic
de nouveau dans l'opposition pendant la
guerre au kosovo pour aujourd'hui faire
plus ou moins clairement acte de
candidature au poste de premier ministre
dans l'opposition mais pas trop vu grâce
kovic se propose de servir milosevic
alors qu'au fond ils ne rêvent que d'une
chose prendre sa place au kosovo les
premiers éléments du contingent russe se
sont déployés prédestine à lille seront
sous les ordres du commandant de forces
internationales de paix d'autres avions
venus de moscou doivent acheminer de
nouveaux soldats russes dans les heures
et les jours qui viennent ceux ci
seraient installés dans le district doha
au match où vivent actuellement
plusieurs milliers de serbes près de
pristina ce sont les soldats anglais qui
doivent maintenant tenter d'organiser du
mieux possible redémarrage des activités
industrielles
ainsi pour la réouverture du complexe
thermoélectrique de dos bilic ou
travailler avant les bombardements de
l'otan 1500 personnes
les militaires britanniques doivent
tenir compte des deux
à la fois albanaise et serbe reportage
agnès vahramian et nathalie gallet en
deux jours la nouvelle s'est vite
répandue la mine de charbon la centrale
électrique le complexe industriel de
bleach est prêt à rouvrir l'usiné est
intacte l'otan dit ne pas l'avoir
bombarder parce que tout simplement elle
ne fonctionnait pas c'est la serbie qui
fournissent l électricité du kosovo la
nouvelle s'est répandue alors les
anciens ouvriers à courre
les albanais les plus pressés chasser ou
partie de l' usine il ya dix ans lors de
la suppression de l'autonomie du kosovo
il était au chômage depuis c'est le
jeune sergent chef terry lee du 20e
régiment de génie britannique qui
négocie les listes de ceux qui
travailleront et aujourd'hui il ya trop
de monde
ne vous inquiétez pas vous rentrerez
tous il faut attendre
on nous a mis dehors en un jour mais on
peut pas revenir aussi vite le jeune
sergent chef a bien préparé son affaire
les s'appuie sur des ingénieurs des
cadres des deux camps à qui il a donné
des assurances alors pendant que les
albanais son travail aujourd'hui s'en
vont de l'autre côté de la route
le sergent rassure les ouvriers serbes
car ces jongleurs terminaux c'est comme
tous d'ailleurs mais il évitera d'en
parler le directeur commercial servent
de lusine a été assassiné la nuit
dernière
il est aux orane kontic qui l'a tué
résume haute expliqué tu sais bien que
l'incident n'a pas eu lieu dans l'usiné
mais chez lui cela ne change rien mais
vous savez qu'au moins qu'au kosovo
on peut nous tuer une vie serbe ne vaut
rien mais cet ingénieur ne ramènera pas
la confiance ses compatriotes l'accusent
même de ne penser qu'à ses intérêts
personnels des serbes
terrorisé des albanais sous-qualifiés le
génie anglais affirme pourtant que dans
quelques jours du charbon sortira de la
mine qu'albanel serbe travailleront
ensemble
pour réparer cette usine vétuste des
compagnies d'électricité privée anglaise
ont même été contactés mais on ne sait
pas qui payera et futur salaire en
israël après six semaines de tractations
politiques plutôt complexe le premier
ministre ehud barak a prononcé son
discours d'investiture à la knesset à
jérusalem monsieur barack appel à une
paix des braves avec les arabes mais la
composition de son gouvernement laisse
un peu perplexe son propre électorat
commentaires charles enderlin premier
ministre s'en va benyamin nétanyahou
quitte la knesset le parlement israélien
il abandonne la vie politique et laisse
sa place au nouveau chef du gouvernement
ehud barak qui dans son discours
d'investiture déclare notre mission
suprême et d'instaurer une paix globale
dans ce proche orient où il ya eu trop
de guerre le nouveau premier ministre
s'est donné un an pour conclure des
traités de paix avec les palestiniens et
la syrie
pour cela il dispose d'une majorité de
plus de 75 sièges sur 120
je pense que la coalition est solide qui
va permettre au premier ministre et à
toute l'équipe
faire un progrès sérieux est
considérable dans le processus de paix
le mot benami fait contre mauvaise
fortune bon coeur
professeur d'université ancien
ambassadeur il briguait les affaires
étrangères où les finances certainement
pas la police et comme de nombreux
travaillistes
il trouve la coalition de monsieur
barack hétéroclite et les accords avec
les orthodoxes surprenant en allemagne
c'est le déménagement du siècle de bonn
à berlin le transfert des meubles et
dossiers les parlementaires a commencé
doit se poursuivre jusqu'au 31 juillet
il ya quand même six cent soixante-neuf
députés et près de 3500 collaborateurs
et fonctionnaires qui change ainsi de
lieu de travail
reportage suivi serrières c'est daniel
lévy
jamais en allemagne un train de
marchandises n'avait suscité un tel
engouement médiatique
5h ce matin le premier convoi en
provenance du bundestag arrive en gare
de berlin
à l'intérieur de ces containers des
meubles et des documents appartenant aux
669 députés du parlement
tout au long du mois de juillet 19
trains comme celui ci seront nécessaires
pour assurer le déménagement le plus
attendu de l'après guerre
celui des institutions fédérales de bonn
à berlin ici au reichstag
la première session parlementaire se
tiendra le 6 septembre prochain
vesna popovich vient de découvrir ses
nouveaux bureaux pour cette française
assistante parlementaire au bundestag
berlin est une capitale naturel pour
l'allemagne je pense qu'à long terme
berlin correspond mieux aux nouveaux
statuts de l'allemagne après la
réunification bonne a toujours été la
capitale provisoire et a toujours été
clair que berlin serait la capitale une
fois l'allemagne réunifiée
c'est le cas maintenant berlin ce n'est
pas seulement la nouvelle capitale de
l'allemagne c'est aussi un pont avec les
fidèles depuis des années autour du
reichstag à berlin est un immense
chantier nouveau bureau nouvelle
chancellerie
la ville veut imposer son dynamisme tout
cela ne plaît guère à friedel droite
pour son restaurant est un véritable
musée de la vie politique ouest allemand
on y voit willy brandt de gaulle et
adenauer friedel rosburg aurait souhaité
que la capitale fédérale reste à bonn
après la catastrophe de la deuxième
guerre mondiale on s'épile à ne plus
jamais de centralisme prussiens plus
jamais l'allemagne devrait être
gouvernée par une seule ville notre
avenir serait celui d'un pays fédéral
bonne petite cité tranquille des bords
du rhin symbolisait la paix dont
l'allemagne avaient besoin pour se
reconstruire après guerre aujourd'hui on
lui préfère berlin et sa nouvelle
postdamer platz élevé sur le no man's
land
symbole de l'affrontement entre l'europe
de l'ouest et l'europe de l'est
la ville de berlin a longtemps fait peur
aux allemands aujourd'hui avec le
transfert des institutions fédérales
la ville de berlin espère devenir la
vitrine d'une allemagne moderne mais qui
regarde son passé avec sérénité
cinq jours après l'accident du
téléphérique du pic de bure dans les
hautes-alpes le procureur de la
république de gap annoncé l'ouverture
une information judiciaire contre x pour
tenter de comprendre ce qui a causé la
mort de 20 personnes
le 1er juillet dernier c'est un
véritable trafic sur le marché français
et dans les pays d'europe du nord qui
vient d'être découverte par les
douaniers du havre un trafic de
préhistorique 315e enfermé dans 21
caisses c'est eux proviennent d'une
espèce d'oiseau du coc ternaire on
l'appelle l'oiseau éléphant et il est
originaire de madagascar
chacun de ces jeux est estimé à plus de
10 mille francs reportage jardine
d'alban morenas et mady diarra
ils sont certes cassé recoller mais
finalement pour leur âge ils sont plutôt
bien conservée saison ont été pondus par
un hacker pierre niess une espèce
disparue il ya plus de mille ans
les douaniers du havre les ont
découverts dans des caisses en
provenance de madagascar
des fossiles protégés par la convention
de l'unesco et qui sont de plus en plus
recherchées par les collectionneurs
c'est the aurait atteint enfin lors
d'une vente à trouver un neuf complet
des pieds ornis aurait atteint le prix
est de 140 mille francs ce qui est
énorme et donc
l'intérêt de la saisie va être peut-être
de ralentir et de réfréner un peu les
ardeurs des collecteurs sauvage au
muséum d'histoire naturelle de paris les
paléontologues français ont réussi à
reconstituer le squelette de cet animal
disparu trois mètres de haut un score
proche de celui de l'autruche un coût et
une tête de dinosaures mais chaque oeuf
qui disparaît sur le marché clandestin
c'est une information perdu un trafic
qui menace toutes les richesses du
patrimoine archéologique
c'est la première fois qu'on saisit ce
type de marchandises en tout cas j'ai
avec le rhume là par contre pour
d'autres types de marchandises genre
produit archéologiques morsure de statut
pour chaude temple ils y arrivent
effectivement en face ce genre de
constatation c'est déjà arrivé ici par
exemple sur des articles en provenance
de thaïlande
les 315 e des pions nice vont maintenant
pouvoir rejoindre leur pays d'origine
qu'il n'aurait jamais dû quitter
madagascar du sport du cyclisme avec le
tour de france l'arrivée de la 3e étape
nantes laval et 10 repetita regardez
bien le belge tom six gagne l'étape au
sprint garde le maillot vert et
l'estonien le voilà tom steels et
l'estonien quercy pew est toujours
maillot jaune
le voici à noter l'échappée quand même
221 km effectués par l'italien massimo
guillou nuit et le français frédéric
guesdon qu mais en vain or le peloton il
y à la caravane du tour de france qui
précède de plusieurs heures le passage
des coureurs avec un lot fourni deux
casquettes et autres gadgets
gracieusement jeté aux foules
c'est aussi cela l'ambiance populaire de
la grande boucle
regardez bien un reportage nathanaël de
rincquesen et alain poirier sur le tour
de france
la vie du loup
ce n'est pas de tout repos on a vous
distribue du fromage la demande est
importante
les stocks convient alors il pourra vite
taillé deux fois par jour et en moins de
deux minutes
deux cent mille
environ 200 milles camembert et 200000
petit coeur en mousse et environ chaque
jour entre 12 et 20 mille suivant les
étapes la caravane empruntent la route
des coureurs environ une heure avant
leur passage
au programme musique klaxon sourire et
cadeaux cette hôtesse lance au public
quatre mille petits sacs jaunes par shu
sur le bord de la route le public
toujours aussi nombreux s'arrachent les
casquettes autocollants et autres
saucissons envoyés par les hôtesses
peu importe le cadeau l'essentiel c'est
d'obtenir quelque chose peut tout dans
leur véhicule
les jeunes filles doivent faire preuve
de prudence un fromage mal donné pour
risquer de vous faire griffer moment je
regarde même pas les faits je regarde
sous les mains savoir celle ci a l'air
d'être agressif c'est ce traité comme ça
non non les têtes je peux pas les voir
de 7 à 77 ans la caravane fait perdre
les esprits à tel point que les parents
en oublie nerfs leur enfant les parents
sont pas content du tout du danger je
crois que tous les ans il ya des
accidents mais bon et encore sur le nom
de deux millions de spectateurs ya je
trouve qui a pas trop de monde quand
même d'accident mais oui il faudrait pas
qu'il y en ait du tout du goût de six
heures par jour
quel que soit le temps ces jeunes filles
se dépensent sans compter
faire le tour de france même dans la
caravane il faut avoir la santé
à l'arrivée les salaires dont de 3500 à
7000 francs suivant les partenaires mais
il place dans la caravane
c'est inestimable l'ambiance des
garanties et les sous
nombre à mamie nova
il était de ceux qui font vivre le
théâtre
l'épitaphe et de jacques chirac saluant
la mémoire de jean pierre darasse décédé
hier à l'âge de 71 ans jean pierre
darasse suite un compagnon de jean vilar
un acteur de cinéma comique il forma
aussi un duo célèbre avec philippe
noiret il avait de l'élégance et de la
truculence dans son talent commenté à
frédéric bonnet avec philippe l'outil la
prolifération et numéro 2 des bêtises
vous présenter un numéro sol en quelque
sorte d'un numéro de soliste provoqué
par bojan pièces et humour et carrière
théâtrale avec philippe noiret jean
pierre darasse fait la preuve que son
destin n'est pas ailleurs que sur la
scène et dont j'ai connu sa famille
c'était vraiment des gens à l'époque
devenir acteur à l'époque cet été
c'était honteux alors ça braie famille
la voici
c'est la grande époque du tnp de jean
vilar en 52 avec ses camarades de
troupes dont gérard philippe jean pierre
darasse apprend les grands classiques du
répertoire c'est quoi si vous n'êtes pas
moi mais moi j'adore les magouilles mais
si vous parlez vous quand j'arriverai
pas m'endormir maintenant les jeunes ne
vois pas quel on voit ça vous est grave
au pied du podium
ne revenez pas tout le temps ça leur a
fait pas un train qui prend vite la voie
du succès celui du vaudeville et de son
comique de situation le comique
peut-être mécanique et humain aussi
moi je crois que si les choses sont
faites sincèrement on peut grimper aux
rideaux
tu te vois encore fatigué par sa mort et
tout vertigineux l'auteur voyage en
train de s'expliquer avec un bios qui ne
te comprends pas et tu as vendu cher de
prière il croit que ce que vous dites et
il te le dis à jean la trilogie ton
pierre darasse c'était jean vilar sacha
guitry
mais surtout marcel pagnol on a dû jouer
ce spectacle je crois près de 400 fois
j'ai eu l'occasion au fil du temps de
voir comment il se confronter au public
mais si tard qu'il se mettait en
disponibilité totale mais ça carpentras
aujourd'hui pour l'ouverture du festival
qu'il a créé il ya huit ans jean pierre
darasse ne sera disponible que dans le
coeur des gens du théâtre même eh bien
je l'aimais bien
c'était un sceptique
il avait de l'humour
pas de qualité que j'apprécie après 50
ans de carrière jean pierre darasse
voulait revenir sur scène avec une
interprétation inédite un molière sont
belles marquises le festival
international de danse à montpellier a
choisi de marier pour cette année le
cinéma et la danse une invitation
magique conduite par philippe decouflé
le chorégraphe raconte une histoire en
images et en réel sur la scène de
montpellier reportage jean jacques
dufour et blaise grenier dans ce monde
devenu village électronique l'image à
des épées magiques car même si l'image
mans elle est aussi mouvement alors à
montpellier sète en cadence que l'image
mène la danse c'était vraiment
l'apologie du mouvement jouant des corps
et des décors l'ambition du peuple et
nous faire rêver ça c'est une recherche
de fantasmagorie quand même le fait des
secrets des effets merveilleux et puis
de montrer des choses c'est de montrer
des choses simples mais de partager des
moments de plaisir avec les gens donc
ensuite si ça vient tout un travail sur
le regard il ya huit projecteurs dans ce
spectacle trois vidéos et cinq films
il ya une direct et il ya du direct de
ce qu'est vidéo c'est en parti prêt
filmé et puis surtout on dirait vraiment
merveilleux et elle est fière ajouté
tu as jeté de la magie magie illusion
projections les images valsent les corps
chaloupés les têtes tournent on perd
l'équilibré parfois la danse quitte la
scène et s'en va glisser sur un mur
d'image entre chorégraphié et
cinématographe
ils sont effectivement des corps york
puisque la danse qu'on voit sur les
écrans c'était dans ce qu'eux-mêmes
fabrique donc sont des chorégraphes
simplement ils ne font plus de
spectacles sur scène leur seule
expression artistique c'est de filmer la
danse qui fabrique et de la mettre dans
des petits écrans qui eux mêmes sont
montés dans une installation l'image
virtuelle images réelles
le mélange nous plonge dans un univers
irréel
ont jeté sur grand écran les corps
échapper à la pesanteur et les
chorégraphes au poids de la réalité
sur scène on peut pas aller regarder
dans l'infini ou quelque chose parce que
ce qu'on voit c'est celle publique et à
la ou les murs du théâtre donc c'est
comme ça donc on peut créer quelque
chose beaucoup plus imaginaires comme
puma
le trou noir en fait ce qu'on peut pas
expliquer c'est très important et le
film pour moi c'est une piste pour
travailler avec st
vendent des quais bus montalvo decouflé
tous utilisent le cinéma ou la vidéo
gros plan ou mavs en travelling la scène
est sens dessus dessous les images
foisonnent les danseurs fusionnent et
tout le monde en redemande
qui a jamais assez d'imagés donc les
images circulent sans arrêt à nous
savoir l'étrier de s'amuser avec de les
comparer ou pas ou de fermer le poste à
propos de tri ne ratez surtout pas le
spectacle de deux couples et shazam vaut
vraiment le coup d'oeil
c'est donc au festival de montpellier
l'auteur du concerto d'aranjuez l'une
des oeuvres pour guitare et orchestre
d'autres les plus connues dans le monde
vient de mourir
le compositeur de ce concerto c'était
croire king rodrigo il avait 97 ans il
avait écrit cette offre que vous
entendez en usant du nom des jardins
royaux d'art en quoi est-ce qu'ils sont
situés dans le sud de la province de
madrid
joachim rodrigo avait écrit aussi de
très nombreuses autres oeuvres musicales
mais qui sont passés et sans doute un
peu inaperçu à l'instar de ce que vous
entendez ce manque est devenu le plus
célèbre concerto mon arrivée à la fin de
ce journal je vous rappelle les
résultats du recensement en france qui
révèle que nous sommes 60 millions 82
mille habitants sur l'ensemble du
territoire
parmi l'élite qui connaissent les plus
fortes croissances nantes toulouse lyon
montpellier et aussi lille
la météo c'est dans quelques secondes
avec sophie davant puis le temps d'une
chanson les plus belles chansons du
monde évoque la famille avec frédéric
mitterrand sera suivie du film sacco et
vanzetti à une heure le journal la
rédaction sera présenté par florence du
fra à 7h50 demain dans les 4 vérités
françoise laborde recevra jacques barrot
l'ancien ministre et puis à 13h vous
trouverez ici même carole gaessler et
rachid arhab sur la route du tour de
france à demain 20h bonsoir merci
oh